it's a look at cause X for a second his
wife was close ex he's my copy on it now
kha'zix is lovely right we really had to
drill the regulative a lot to 2x4 why is
that why is this so much a nice thought
to do with the sightings great when you
look at the stationary points the
technical is I should say the turning
points are course the problems right
everything's looking good here for a
long time
all the way through or view angles and
on the obtuse angles that's a very
natural way to I'm looking things and
then of course you stop because you want
to everyone okay
so highlight with me what to PI just
like before you need to say because it
doesn't work but kha'zix has no inverse
function cos x in this domain does have
any of those function so we define this
as the domain that gives you that cos
inverse so I can say y equals cos x in a
different domain from multiplying that
has the first function and that's what
we define as causing us
okay now I want you to close for a
second and have a look at the top right
hand side of the board one of those guys
what are they you recognize them right
viv Sandra and the cosine rule right now
we learned both of those in the context
of like what kinds of problems could be
solved with this time rule or the cosine
rule that we couldn't solve before what
did these let us do triangles specific
or any triangle yeah triangles the dirt
have writings we started cycles of ten
from planning the triangles and then as
soon as we were out of there we're like
kind of stuck and that's why we had to
develop these okay what specifically can
you find with the sign rule all of
Kirsten what kinds of things with the
evaluate yeah good so you can find a
length right or alternatively you could
find an angle those are the pieces in
here right if you've got say for
instance two sides and an angle right so
long as they're in the right
configuration down posing each other and
so on you can find the angle that's
missing right but at this one what would
I need if I want to find angle here yeah
I need all three sides right because if
I don't have all three I don't know like
three sides is what gives me Congress so
I know exactly which triangle is because
I've got all three sides right so if I
know exactly which angle now we kind of
view them as very synonymous because
they both can solve the same thing I can
rearrange by other days to find
scientists at angles okay but we
establish that these two are not the
same the cosine rule is clearly superior
for solving those kinds of problems why
in this context
yeah okay good good good
the short answer is yes but you've
actually come at it from another angle
so I'm gonna come back to your point if
that's okay right the problem was if you
use the side rule you actually can get
the angle wrong can get the wrong angle
okay you can find each angle when
actually it was obtuse because you're
looking at the wrong triangles it has to
do with the fact that I'm you know how
you say when you've got two sides and an
angle if you don't have them included
then you're in trouble it's the same
thing with the same rule if you don't
have them in the right spot then yeah
you just make him ask yourself right we
can reestablish this before now have a
look at the inverse trig functions and
you can see where the problem arises
right this guy when you reverse him he
doesn't know her which of these angles
you mean because they'll always give you
the same value back right and he can't
ever if you can't it's needed by the
nature of side or just cuz I never has
this problem right the biggest angle you
can get I'm not 2 pi because the end was
undefined will of course is yes okay so
therefore no happy bad angle is it's
gonna be somewhere in here where as
triangles all around the world has
angles of this size of this size and
this size okay so you see this is
explaining why the cosine rule is always
better and why the ambiguous case exists
it's because you don't have a choice
when you define it does that make sense
okay so establish this I want you to
know that like you need to have this
picture in your head when I first saw as
I'm running please when I was in year 12
I didn't understand what's going on so
all I did was I took this and I took
this and I said okay I'll just remember
their problem do you think I encountered
when I took those two boxes without the
pictures you say
memorize what probably makes that's
something I spoke there right so when I
was doing I could never go my god which
ones might aspire to budget I have their
reference sheet right so I had all kinds
of volunteer if you have a picture in
your head you can see why I can do this
right it's now turning points and if you
have the picture in your head you can
see why you have to be it's weird I mean
it's cuz of the turning points right
let's finish the drawings where did you
draw 10x where did you draw what do
think yeah you match the domain of sign
don't you but it's for a different
reason
what was the reason this time yeah how
many 20 points is 10 her answer right so
I've got this guy by the way again
because your nerves for Malik and radio
Misha what's the gradient an X at the
origin it's one so you should be able to
draw in that 45 degree line through that
but you've got these guys what are the
patient's of Masters x equals so in
between here we're good we're happy okay
so I'm not going to write it again
you've got this guy over here except
this 10x but it's the same domain
does that make sense correct as opposed
to this one where you can get to how
much punch it in time to that was the
whole point of the drawing of my
asymptotes in but one difference is that
you don't have those so there are all of
our drawings of the regulatory functions
we need three more drawings to accompany
them the three drawings that are kind of
implied here which three we actually
can't do them they gotta take this moss
I'm not gonna do the mouse yeah the
actually Festus right we defined them
but we don't know what they look like
okay now it's not difficult
I'm gonna give you some time
I went around and missed rifle as well
tell her look at how you going begin do
that trick retain do the reflection it's
very easy to get the arms the actually
could cavity all I kind of thing wrong
because we used to draw it like this
okay everything's going to be reversed
so take some time
do all these nice and big so that you
can make sure that the temperature is
accurate and once you've got those
otherwise no questions for one being
that may be able to do these definitions
okay